non
[Musique]
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes au sud de la russie dans la
ville de krasnodar
c'est l'une des villes qui a connu la
plus grande croissance du pays elle
compte aujourd'hui presque 1 million
d'habitants elle est surtout la capitale
administrative du craj de krasnodar
située sur le fleuve de cuban qui donne
le nom à sa région historique et
géographique à partir du xviiie siècle
cette région a été peuplée par les
cosaques un groupe social organisés
militairement qui gardait les frontières
sud de l' empire russe
ils avaient leurs propres traditions
leur mode de vie et leur folklore
cependant après la révolution de 1917
les cosaques ont perdu leurs
particularismes et la plupart de leurs
traditions ont également disparu
mais depuis la chute de l'union
soviétique des communautés de cosaques
commence tard en est un regain d'intérêt
pour les traditions commencent à se
manifester non seulement auprès des
locaux mais aussi auprès des gens
d'autres continents comme notre invité
d'aujourd'hui il s'appelle johnattan pp
il est originaire de côte d'ivoire et il
fait partie du groupe
maroussia justement le voilà allant
faire sa connaissance johnatan sein du
salut comment tu vas ça va très bien
elle va bien ça va très bien je suis
content d'être là moi aussi j'ai envie d
écouter un peu de musique un peu tout ça
alors est ce que tu peux me dire
maroussia c'est quoi mao ca c'est un
collectif
nous sommes tous des jeunes africains et
nous chantons des chasseurs russes à ses
origines j'ai avec des costumes de gaza
qui est très bien qu'est ce que tu fais
toi dans cette dans ce groupe et bls
groupe chez plume à tout faire ouais
j'ai changé je danse je joue au tampa
mais sans sa permission aux percussions
ouais ça va être dur hard la musique
aujourd'hui savait très simple en tout
cas qu'est ce qu'on fait ici alors
ces jours de répétition d'accord donc
ils vivent à gogo
[Musique]
google wave ou se rendre à guérande
estivales
lundi ciel et commencent à songer à
point
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
tous en russie à peu près septième année
4 ans et 5 ans et vous venez d'où tous
alors quand tu vois cameroun comoé votre
langue commune
c'est le français vous êtes étudiant
pour l'occupant nous sommes étudiants en
a qui ont fini leur cycle est bon moi
présentement je suis encore étudiant
moi aussi je suis continuer à étudier
quel qu'il soit ce que tous les autres
participants ont les meilleurs résultats
de l'institut tout le monde travaille
bien au chaud combinent leurs études et
les activités de groupes mais leur étude
sur la priorité nous comprenons que le
plus important c'est leur métier et la
vie artistique n'est qu'une aide pour
mieux connaître notre pays
est ce que vous vous voyez après vos
études continuer à vivre en russie
les décisions je n'ai pas le temps parce
que le budget après bon personnellement
moi j'ai fini chantepie
ouais ouais les faux presse km à l'est
schering et pourquoi je suis revenu
bon je m'enferme six mois pas dit
comment il fait médecine et les médecins
ici c'est vrai les développe t parce que
je vais jean colloque
je suis né avec une mission au pays pour
ma médecine est retourné chez moi
la suite va dépendre de six lits à une
opportunité de travail parce que c'est
un travail après des études on ne
pourrait pas quand même resté à errer là
sachant que pour moi ce groupe c je veux
dire à une passion mais parle métier
[Musique]
commencée il ya 10 ans on était en route
pour assister à un événement culturel
avec un de nos amis un étudiant africain
de notre université à krasnodar est déjà
là nous avions le sentiment que lorsque
des étrangers chante les chansons
populaires d'un autre pays
cela leur donne une signification
spéciale une sonorité spéciales et les
gens le centre toute chose tout
[Musique]
j'ai eu
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on n'a pas de chanteurs professionnels
ou personnels diplômés voire de musique
mais il s'intègre très vite et leur
talent s'améliore alors raconte moi ça
fait ça fait longtemps que tu es dans le
groupe ouais ça fait
neuf ans et demi par la coupe ça fait
déjà une bonne tête longtemps
est ce que pour toi c'est un loisir
c'est un travail on peut dire et loisirs
travail parce que j'aime
la musique depuis l'afrique jouait déjà
au djembé
comment les tam tam tam africain tu
joues d'autres d'instruments aussi la
batterie la guitare pas trop mais voilà
je dois ici c'est le temps que mon ami
n'est ici il y avait une émission
minutes à son avis la minute de la boire
ouais donc ils avaient besoin des
percussionnistes
donc c'est comme ça puis on trouve dans
le groupe on te croise dans la rue
parfois on te dit tiens à ce que
maus est et populaire en russie mais
d'avoir un personnage parce que nous
venons ici
donc ça n'a pas été trop dur justement
durant la pandémie c'est que ça a été
très dur parce qu'on avait beaucoup de
prestations qui ont été annulés donc ça
a beaucoup joué dessus
des finances a beaucoup joué mais où tap
a essayé de faire des conserves yazoo en
interne on a juste fait avec ma roue ça
on en a fait un projet pour le 9 mai ce
qu'il a fait ici nous avons chanté une
chanson et ce mobile en cas donc ça a
été beaucoup aimé beaucoup partagé dans
toute la russie
il ya des amis qui m'écrivait depuis
moscou saint pétersbourg pas reconnus
sur la vidéo même de l'africom a écrit
[Musique]
et que commencent à tuer je crois que tu
es marié ici
oui je suis marié j'ai varié avec une
russe ou avec une beaucoup de chance et
ma femme elle est restée africaines
auxquelles nous nous sommes connus au
studio d'enregistrement
donc j'ai la musique qui vous a dit
ouais elle a fait partie du groupe
maroussia elle a joué pendant un bon
moment mais elle a quitté le groupe
quand elle était enceinte
jonathan est né en 1990 à tafiré une
petite ville située au nord de la côte
d'ivoire
son père est professeur de sciences
naturelles au collège et sa mère est
commerçante
leur maison est toujours pleine de vie
jonathan a deux frères et deux soeurs
après avoir obtenu son pack jonathan des
ménages à yamoussoukro la capitale du
pays pour poursuivre ses études il entre
à l'institut national polytechnique
l'une des meilleures universités
ivoiriennes à l'école supérieure des
travaux publics
après deux ans d'études jonathan obtient
par concours avec cinq autres étudiants
ivoiriens une bourse du ministère russe
des affaires étrangères
fin 2011 il est envoyé à krasnodar où il
est tout d'abord inscrit en cours de
préparation pour étudier la langue russe
ensuite il entre à l'institut du pétrole
du gaz et de l'énergie
sept ans après en 2018 il obtient le
diplôme d'ingénieur forage quand
jonathan entre à l'institut
il entend parler du groupe maroussia et
il intègre pour gagner un peu d'argent
il commence à participer de plus en plus
souvent aux concerts un jour une
nouvelle chanteuse rejoint le collectif
elle s'appelle pauline à son père et
ougandais et sa mère russe
grâce à cette belle voix qu'elle doit
une éducation musicale poussée elle
devient membre permanent du groupe
marcoussiens jonathan tombe amoureux
d'elle et trois ans plus tard ils se
marient au cours des années suivantes
ils ont deux enfants justyna et rochelle
l'année dernière pauli d'acquis
maroussia et s'engage dans un autre
ensemble musical le groupe monte carlo
fête est difficile pour toi d'apprendre
le russe
oui bien sûr la langue russe et ne
risquez pas comme les autres 1 nous
arrivons ici est une faculté de langues
ou les étrangers apprennent les risques
pendant une année
comment je suis arrivé en retard donc
juste six mois pour apprendre la langue
russe ça a été très accéléré très
compliqué tu parlais avec vous déjà des
russes j'ai parlé mais on me disait tout
le temps
1 qu'est ce que tu as dit parlement un
petit peu aussi des relations avec les
avec les russes c'est notre mentalité en
manière dont il travaille doit manier
donc dont ils réfléchissent sa
différence est différent l'afrique est
un très chaud on bouge beaucoup et c'est
un peu plus qu'un galloway
il aimerait un petit peu aussi le
folklore non j'imagine les aime bien de
folklore pour l'histoire nous avons
aussi avec des amis un groupe de chants
et de danses africaines c'est les russes
aiment beaucoup près
[Musique]
parlons un petit peu du climat parce que
on est au sud de la russie donc c'est un
petit peu plus chaud ça t'a sauvé un
petit peu ça un petit peu parce que
l'histoire est que ak sanaa quand il
fait chaud il fait très chaud même plus
chaud qu'en côte d'ivoire
mais quand il ya le froid il fait très
très très très facilement le webzine
extrêmes coin très chaud très froid en
russie c'est la première fois que
j'avais vu la neige
oui on a même goûté un peu tout ça
[Musique]
vous avez un petit appartement vous avez
acheté c'est ça ouais
on crée un petit appartement sis
al'avantage aussi en russie n'ont pas
notre cas russie a créé ça ne s'est pas
trop cher donc on peut se permettre de
vraiment quelque chose et puis on est
donc là aujourd'hui ta femme et tes
enfants soient en barges lira maison et
on y voit un lego c'est clair
[Musique]
alors si vous vivez ses services et si
nous vivons c'est au dynamo femmes
bonjour en français jeannette tu parle
français
un petit peu alors quand est-ce que vous
avez déménagé y sera je devrais me 3 -
par lettre d'accord
les travaux continuent leur manque de
fini mais c'est vous qui fait les
travaux non c'est son nom parle c'est
parce qu'ils nous aident à celle états
unis soit dans le double m alors il ya
les enfants parce qu'on les entend bien
là et ça ils sont bien excité c'est ça
les informer gays sont au chaud
certaines essences d'eyepet donne 5 et
super départ alors les enfants comment
comment vous vous appelez quel âge tu as
toi et toi tu as quel âge
dès 2 ans alors comment ça vous parler
en français tu parles en france est
nécessaire et forcer mais c'est
difficile parce que tout un ris à
l'économie là j'essaie de mettre les
dessins animés en français j'essaie de
ne pas les juste en face à va est ce que
les enfants font de la musique aussi
[Musique]
bravo à ces deux chansons russes près de
dix ans alors qui va à l'école déjà ici
là je gomme la plus grande île à l'école
t as pas mieux chez soi
[Musique]
elle joue à quoi j'ai vu une balle de
football un jour au football ça vienne
et qu est-ce qu est-ce qui a d'autres
comme jeu qu'est ce qu'elle aime faire
elle aime qu'on lui doit trouver son
salut le chat c'est litois a trouvé dans
la rue n'est trouvée dans la vie c'est
ça va briller il avec nos vêtements ça
fait là il s'amusait avec les enfants il
savait les enfants et leurs abords oui
mais heureux
[Rires]
[Musique]
la crise la pandémie ou comment vous
l'avez vécu
vous l'avez vécu ici vous étiez ailleurs
quand ça s'est passé et futur de la cour
ailleurs c'est pendant la crise qu'on a
acheté notre nouvelle voiture c'est
pendant la crise qu'on a vu cette
nouvelle maison j'ai fait le métier
comme j'avais une voiture je suis à
l'étranger tandis que les taxis eux et
aujourd'hui c'est s'est passé il ya un
seuil est survenu comme avant a beaucoup
les conseils qui sont annulés jusqu'à
présent tant que j'aurai beaucoup j'ai
pratiquement pas des jeux de retour
j'étais avec un jour un minimum entre 12
et 16 heures à jouer et toi pauline qui
a souvent des concerts aussi où mon
milieu concept seat chasse fait chuter
la za vous me les africains ici sur
place vous avez une grande communauté
vous côtoyez que les ivoiriens vous
voyez les camerounais voyez un petit peu
tout le monde comment ça se passe le
tout à tout le monde nous sommes très
bien organisée nous avons un président
de tous les afriques et un haut niveau
de la discipline et nous avons au niveau
des étudiants une augmentation des
ivoiriens qui étudie en russie au niveau
de la communauté africaine nous sommes
tous en somme mais il ya toujours des
problèmes pendant les réunions parce
qu'il ya plus de francophones et
d'anglophones docteur darrieux qui ont
commencé par un parfait et il va me
falloir nous dira juste un grand merci
j'ai passé un excellent moment merci m
aujourd'hui nous accompagnons maroussia
200 km de krasnodar la route va être
longue mais sûrement pas ennuyeuse nous
sommes enfin arrivés dans le village
musée dataman
[Musique]
c'est la reproduction de la vie
quotidienne des cosaques du kubang ce
lieu n'a pas été choisi par hasard il
existait autrefois une forteresse
turquie a été conquise par les cosaques
sous le règne de catherine 2 qui leur a
donné cette terre
[Musique]
aujourd'hui maroussia une répétition
générale dans ce village
[Musique]
m
ouah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fatigués mais satisfaits du travail bien
fait le chantre rejoignent krasnodar
pour reprendre des forces
il reste à l'équipe maroussi encore
beaucoup de prestations aux quatre coins
du pays et des moments de plaisirs
musicaux à partager j'aurais te demander
est ce que ta patrie tu manques
oui ce qui te manque le plus familier
lan ou de la bouffe oui beaucoup
pour comparer des choses spécifiques à
le cube maggi les côte d'ivoire ouais je
l'est toujours mais fini qu'est ce que
tu as appris en russie la russie m'a
donné une famille l'éducation une
culture la compréhension de comment
vivent les autres peuvent pas selon les
russes parce qu'il est étudié avec
beaucoup de la société est ce que tu
peux me donner un fait marquant qui t'es
arrivé en russie
il y en a beaucoup c'était de monter sur
la scène 2
la minute de la loi c'est des choses
inexplicables c'est à dire je vais
jamais pu penser que je pourrais tu es
new et aussi à la naissance des enfants
le folklore kozak way où le folklore de
côte d'ivoire
pourquoi n'y voit pas que d'ivoire ouais
pourquoi parce qu'à la base je suis
percussionniste et j'aime jouer autant
femmes africaines ouais et ça me manque
trop grave
le tam tam africain où le tambour du
caucase maintenant un tombeau du caucase
maintenant parce que j'essaie de me
perfectionner avec toujours tom tom
afrique est donc sévère toujours incliné
à côté de mon lit les parce que tout le
temps écoute je te remercie vraiment
très profondément j'ai passé un moment
extraordinaire c'est moi qui voulais
essayer
ouais merci merci vsc
notre émission touche à sa fin j'espère
que vous avez apprécié le folklore
musical
kozak chanté par nos amis maroussia
ainsi que notre invité jonathan tpsa
magnifique famille le nouvelle aventure
de nouveaux lieux tout aussi intéressant
vous attendent
je vous dis à très bientôt sur arte
france
[Musique]